you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Ches calm
and I just got paired up playing a 500
game
let's try knight c6 move one against e
for your transpose into a scotch or
something along those lines but no okay
this is the idea yeah my Bishop on c5
I'm just wondering if I should go there
straight away let's play Knight f6 first
you know what not
maybe I play Bishop b4 if they stop it
with Bishop here no so Bishop c5 d6 I
may want to hold off on counseling also
maybe I even go with a six right now
mm-hmm
now let's get d6 in there's some some
little bothering type of moves Knight a4
and maybe even b4 at this point and I
can't take because of Queen here but now
I'm gladly do this to preserve my bishop
and we can quickly see some type of a
attack brew against a white king let's
just pre-emptive move against v4 and I'm
gonna make one more kind of waiting move
to see if they're quick to castle
I may look for night h5 and to f4 Queen
g5 and even some possibilities for a
night here hmm
so they're holding off with King side
castles let's play Knight h5 right now
before it's maybe not a possibility have
some offsetting Knights fighting for
these two squares night into f4 is a
pretty invasive piece the ruling that
out but at the same time h3 is now a bit
vulnerable hmm what would they do if I
played Queen f6
let's find out how they meeting the
threat of mate pretty serious do
something ugly like Bishop here my queen
can also look at this square hitting it
too unprotected pieces hmm I think
they're in trouble
Bishop III takes Queen c3 f4 I have
enough two defenders on that square
could just take away yeah just by how
long they're spending here I don't know
that there's a defense a good one at
least we're gonna take him out and then
I believe just Queen f3 straight away
Queen on e3 isn't kind of get trapped
let's do it Queen f3 to e3
o Kings running you get the g3 pawn my
Queen isn't going to get trapped I don't
think let's do it I have this square
covered in case they try to chase my
Queen away I didn't see that move he's
packing up and running there are some
open files towards my king if I want to
Castle kingside still if I go Queen side
this is actually a little bit scary as
well these pawns so close on h4 I could
think about h5 and maybe camping out on
the g4 square be mindful of rook g1
taking out my Jeep on these two minor
pieces aren't playing so it's really
like the heavy pieces that I'm concerned
about I think I might want to just play
Queen h4 hmm just to rely upon a square
for my queen yeah let's let's is there
something better three minutes left I'm
going to go with Queen h4 before h4 is
played
and I could get I guess I could look
forward to castles King side do I really
want to do that
it's awfully scary going either way
really c5 and the sacrifices here I'm up
upon but it doesn't feel like I'm up
upon hmm yeah this could be tricky no
doubt I'm gonna try and weather some
storm here I'm looking at King h7 rook
g8 and then maybe I can move my knight
next some slow building up moves Bishop
d7 I was considering Bishop d7 on my
last turn fortunately these guys aren't
playing if I'm trying to get in this
thematic pawn break it's gonna require a
lot of work I weakened some G file
squares definitely can't move my knight
now I want to be able to move my knight
so let's play King h7 and rook to g8
soon okay where's that night going
probably heading for f5 maybe King h7
wasn't best
I am opposite the bishop the Knights
gonna drop in here she'll probably
combat that let's play 97 if I could
control the knight i control these
pieces i imagine he's going to move how
exactly to take hmm okay this is getting
hit mm there's their queen trap if I
play Bishop here Queen takes pawn rook
f8 I think the Queen would be trapped
now she could go to h5 let's just defend
hmm yeah my queen is short on squares
but
actually pretty scary minute 32 I'm
gonna try it still I think yeah this is
scary excuse me
night in here and then I have to worry
about rook G for stuff or that move Wow
okay probably Bishop here and then rook
to f8 wow I'm up upon but again it does
now feel like I am up upon this is
unprotected soon to be struck out this
is my idea next to get rid of that
Knight now that I have f6 controlled
it's my queen and rook scary you can
think about winning this pawn I can't
get on the H file too easily yeah Rick
h1 the Knights defending I feel like I
should still go for it though let's try
it it's ready to make a recapture that's
not possible
yeah that was probably not a good
decision I could give the cleanup
could try to do that
yeah cuz Knight f5 is hitting soon okay
we're gonna be playing this position
without the Queen soon okay let's just
make a move right into one of these two
is happening or even here I'm not
getting two pieces he doesn't have to do
that my queen is without any squares
okay I have a couple pawns for it it's
about it this was a really just like a
passing move should have come up with
something better
yeah she's officially without any
squares I should have played Bishop to
ei t' to have this diagonal I guess
they're looking for more and are they
gonna get more huh
okay I think they could have just got
two pieces for it by getting mated we're
gonna find out their bishops not playing
let's get this guy here Bishop to ei t'
a little cage here for my king
a little cage defend 37 seconds down to
the wire double up and I think I want to
you know that Bishop that Queen I think
I want to stop the clean from going
anywhere
let's go here get active get this square
for my night it's in the center there
are some checks no my night is covering
some squares hmm let's play Bishop here
you probably know I'm on the Queen and
the bishop Wow down to the wire this is
gonna be a time time thing rook takes
pawn was maybe a move actually why did I
take the Queen time pressure I could've
just taken the Queen less than 10
seconds what a messy game
oh I have a you don't get you don't get
that chance too many times to different
chances to take the copy and this is
gonna be a quick review of this game
messy messy messy up upon but activity
for team light I didn't see that King
move hmm yeah that was that was pretty
scary for sure I think just the night
retreat right around here let me go to
that position let me flip the board yeah
just a night retreat they didn't have to
they didn't have to do a rucksack here I
was thinking one of these two at the
night but where's my Queen gown night
one of these two why not here and what
am I doing this my queen she's cooked I
needed to I guess right around this
point I needed to my bishop or just not
have captured on h3 at all and come up
with something else just tough to do
because of this space over here for
white I don't see any pawn advances on
the Queen side is benefiting me and do I
have any pawn advances over here that
benefits me just like it feels like if I
go at that five well forget about what
it feels like this is what does happen
if I play a five I help this piece out
the King position my decision ago its
King aged seven is a bit debatable hmm
probably when I had this idea of
securing g7 I should have played King
age 8 and then rook to g8 maybe that was
a better idea and also coming to think
of it maybe a better way I could have
organized my pieces was first getting in
Bishop d7 and then when I play rook g8
and if this pawn is attacked I can
immediately come over with this instead
of playing f6
playing f6 really weakened my position
creating some holes on both the g6e 6
which wasn't so much of a factor
the e6 square but certainly g6 yeah this
is probably a little bit of an
improvement but could I have done
something better I mean I'm winning up
on but yeah I mean f3 and King to d2 and
he's just just bolting out there hmm
yeah I don't know I feel like it's a it
would be reading as an even position
even though I'm up up on there maybe b4
is sooner I think white could be saving
some time if they want to expand on the
queenside as soon as I played e6 this is
an opportunity to get in v4 and takes
there's Queen a4 and there goes my
bishop so they don't need this prep move
is what I'm getting out the a3 move they
know what the the eighths remove that
they played on move 9 they can do
without that they could play b4 right
now and save a move and they'll just be
that much faster - expanding on the
Queen side but as it was played out
Bishop d2 is in a way a bit of a passing
move I'm kind of doing the same if
they're going king side instead yeah
maybe this isn't the best passing move
because this is an idea maybe this is a
better passer move Bishop there and then
suppose castles this type of stuff can
be a bit scary objectively probably bad
but for blitz who knows what can happen
fishing pole ideas both bishops pointing
in this direction should the knight be
captured White's always having to work
around a completely opened H file
that's what I was trying to do my
opponent was clearly aware of it by
making these uh you know half moves I
guess we could say a three h3 Bishop d2
before castling well he didn't castle in
the game but I'll have a look at it with
the computer Queen f6 I think is the
right move but yeah even though I'm off
upon here scary they have all their
pieces playing there's certainly
compensation here with a locked center
place should come in the wings and yeah
white house play on the wings here we'll
see what the suggestions are with the
stock fish and see what we can learn
from it okay stock fish let's see what
you have to say about this position
coming up let's just get right into this
defined center Bishop c5 well I could
already play Knight to g4 here oh wow
huh as early as move seven I could
converge on this square taking advantage
of the fact that the knight isn't
controlling these two squares h4 and g5
actually forget about g5 h4 is available
to my queen oh just the typical castles
can be met with Queen h4 and this is
already lights-out we don't we don't
reach move 10 in this game Wow
quick strike at f2 I was caught up
talking about do I play d6 do I play a
six
I can already strike it f2 noted
that's very beginner ish too I should be
looking it well it's it's like a
beginner ish idea but I mean it's
clearly the best move here the quick
convergence on the f2 square or the the
c2 square but yeah with the night on e 2
this is available huh
Computers pointing out as mentioned
before can be played they went with h3 I
preserve my bishop I could go right in
for night h5 I tucked the bishop away
first and now play Knight h4 now I do
this passing move first finally night h4
oh no no I have it wrong night h4 is
this
I played night h5 in this position but
Knight h4 as well is a move striking a
g2 I was focused on the f4 square night
h5 g3 and it doesn't want to play Queen
f6 there is rook h2 here oh I guess we
were really both blind to that one I was
saying if the RIP place to f1 I take h3
but there is a defense with rook h2 well
okay they go on Castle but still they
maintain upon and you know maybe they
get enough for break in if they still
have the F pawn around what could I do
different around here it does want to go
in for the line I played Queen f3 and
then taking on g3 but how could I better
manage this position Bishop d7 for
starters or castles I castled I played
the Queen first just fine
now I castled
King h7 yeah it's it's holding but yeah
it's uncomfortable for sure b5 hmm I
didn't think about I didn't think about
moving pawns over here why not we are I
was gonna say we're both castled on
opposite wings well I'm castled at least
White's not I didn't even try to take
advantage of the King being in the
center I was too focused on defensive
roles freeing up my night playing her to
GA but in reality where is this night
even gonna go I don't think he has a
good square to move to I shouldn't be
looking to even move my knight I could
look for this idea Bishop d7 and b5 let
me just make some passing mos b5 and
well if they take okay this is helpful
for my rook but suppose they just bypass
D takes B takes and now c6 it wants to
go with rook F to b8
hmm I guess I don't need defense over
here just having my pawn around to
defend the knight my knight can't be
kicked and then I'm looking for B for
looking to get at the King on the Queen
side I was too preoccupied with
defensive things I need things I thought
I needed to defend but I guess I don't
really need to do this to secure the g7
square I guess um my train of thought is
really you know if I see one of my
pieces in a position where he's
restricted I'll immediately look to try
and free him up but where why am i
freeing him up like he doesn't really
have he doesn't have a good
think to do like where's where is he
going to improve he's not going to f4
can't go to e5 in the game he went to e7
but yeah I guess I could just get on
with playing on the queenside just too
preoccupied with this major pieces on
the G file so Bishop d7 would have been
better with some b5 idea and I guess
this is still fine just keeping these
pawns sitting g8
it's suggesting v5 again and now after
this move doesn't like it
yeah Bishop d7 again it's his only
square I should get there and now it's
even and kind of tough to play I played
Bishop d7 here yes okay to f8 it's
liking me now g6 is okay and this pawn
is probably just poison you know all
these moves here you only see the top
suggestion but I see another one as well
there's a five there's c6 just looking
to open it up and keep this sitting
I don't know why I felt the need to grab
this pawn I mean not a need that's the
wrong term but I mean I could definitely
be doing some other stuff than giving
them another file to work with I don't
like I don't think I like much at all
how I play this game yeah I mean right
out of the gate missing a Knight to g4
move and now I'm just giving away my
queen Bishop e8 I needed to play and now
it's gone for me and they didn't they
didn't do the right move Knight f2 or f1
or e2 it's both good my Queen's dead
they captured first Queen h5 it's an
advantage for white but you know a tough
one to convert because I do have some
coordination
and once we got here what else was
missed
very imbalanced there should be five is
fine and I should just be taking the
Queen
we're in Bullitt mode but I mean I
pointed it out I could take the Queen or
maybe take here they probably have to
just take on c7 after I played Bishop b5
we can take c7 Bishop takes e - and we
have this type of an end game - Rick's
versus the Queen and we just turn out to
be a rat race in this 500 but you know
gave me two chances to take their queen
in this one
and they just dropped their time from
here but Messi game really all over
knight c6 is an interesting line I
played it in Bullitt and blitz never in
some serious game but some interesting
attacks that spring about and as we're
seeing as early as this move seven it's
really a killer shot Knight to g4 not
really a good defense of f2 King side
castle Queen h4 striking it both h2 and
f2 and they're gonna be dropping in
exchange soon discovered checks right
around the corner they have to invest
the rook yeah this could have been over
a long while ago the form of ten little
detail with the b4 move and the Queen a4
idea
and also Knight to h4 was something else
to look into striking at g2 hmm okay
well I took some things away from this
one even though it was a little bit
messy and
if you have any feedback you'd like to
leave in the comment section below
feel free to do that and as always I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you